The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
TADGE DRYJA: OK.
So today, Discreet Log
Contracts which is very linked
to Lightning Networks.
So if you didn't get
the last two lectures,
this might not make
that much sense.
So I hope-- but I think
everyone here is like up
to date on these things.
So today, I'm going to talk
about Discreet Log Contracts,
which is a paper I
wrote last summer,
but it's evolved out
of Lightning Network.
And I'll try to sort
of explain how it--
hopefully, you'll see the
connections and how you
can get from one to the other.
We'll talk about oracles, talk
about anticipated signatures,
which has some fun
math things, and talk
about building the Discreet
Log Contracts themselves
and how that'll work.
OK, so conditional
payments, I guess
you could call this
smart contracts.
Smart contracts is
a pretty vague term,
and it's used a lot in this
sort of Bitcoin, blockchain,
Ethereum world.
And usually, it's pretty--
like, a lot of times,
they use it as a buzzword
and it's like, oh, I'll put my
land title in a smart contract
and then I can buy a house.
And a lot of times,
it's used in ways
that make it seem as though you
don't need a government anymore
or a judicial system anymore
to enforce these contracts.
And in the case of something
like Discreet Log Contracts,
that's kind of true.
Because what
Bitcoin did and what
made people pretty
impressed was that, hey,
you don't need a
government to enforce
the scarcity of the currency
that's being created.
So that's kind of cool.
But it doesn't mean that you can
now use blockchain technology
to not need a government
to enforce, say, rights
to property.
If you say, hey, this
is my land and I've
got a smart contract that
says my land is-- you know,
this is my land
on the blockchain,
and then an army comes and says,
well, we're taking your farm,
and you're like, no,
it's on the blockchain,
and they don't really care.
So it's hard-- like,
another way to think
about it is the only thing
the Bitcoin network can do
is move Bitcoin,
and the only thing
the Ethereum network can do is
move Ethereum, to some extent.
It doesn't extend out
to like, you know,
autonomous drones to
shoot you if you trespass
or anything like that yet.
OK, so the simplest
and, I think,
most straightforward and
maybe the most useful type
of smart contract is a
conditional payment where
it's basically, I'm
going to pay you
based on some external data.
So I'm going to use the
example of Alice and Bob
betting on tomorrow's weather.
If it rains, Alice gets a coin.
If it's sunny, Bob gets a coin.
And we need some kind of
way to get this data, right.
OP_WEATHER is not in Bitcoin.
And I think, yeah,
bet is a word that--
it's weird.
Like, when I'll meet
with fancy rich people,
like who are in companies
that come to the Media Lab--
no, I still use the word bet.
Like, to me, everything's
a bet, right?
Insurance is a bet.
Like, if I buy car insurance,
I'm betting GEICO or whatever.
Bet I'm going to crash my car.
And they're like,
I bet you won't.
And then if I crash my car,
they're like, aw, shoot,
and then they give
you the money.
And if I get health
insurance, I'm like,
I bet I'm going to get cancer.
And then they're
like, bet you won't.
And then if I get
cancer, I win and I
get a whole bunch of money.
Right.
Well, so they're
offset by the fact
that you don't actually
want to get cancer
and you don't want
to crash your car.
And so the fact that you're
betting that you will do it
means that, in the case
that something bad happens,
you get a bunch of money
to defer this cost.
But fundamentally, from the
insurance company's perspective
and your perspective in
this insurance contract,
it's a bet about whether
you're going to do this or not.
And like almost all the
financial contracts,
you can look at as bets,
like derivatives and futures
and all those kinds of things.
OK, so to keep it
simple for the example,
there's a very limited
set of outcomes.
Right?
It's either rainy
or sunny tomorrow,
and we don't know that it's
going to-- what the weather is
going to be tomorrow yet, and
we're going to bet the coin.
OK.
So yeah, we need oracles.
And I would argue that
the Lightning Network
script is essentially a
smart contract, right,
the this key now or
this other key later.
In Lightning, however, we
don't have external state.
Right?
There's no need to
query a third party.
query the outside world.
And all the data that
is used in the channel
is generated by the participants
of the channel themselves.
Right?
They're making up random keys,
throwing them-- you know,
sending them to each other just
so that they can negotiate over
the balances in that channel.
That said, they're probably
exchanging something outside
of the scope of the system.
Right?
They're probably
trading, you know,
I'll give you a little bit
of Bitcoin for some cookies,
or something like
that, and there's
some delivery of goods or
services that's not in Bitcoin.
But for the state itself,
it's all internal.
If we want external
state, we need
some way to get that external
state into our system.
Usually, this is
called an oracle.
OK, so the simplest oracle
would be two of three multisig,
and there are
places that do this.
And it's not-- I don't want to
say it's like a stupid idea.
It's actually quite powerful.
And Bitcoin enables it in ways
that you couldn't necessarily
do before, but there's
problems with it.
OK, so if you just say
two of two multisig,
where Alice and Bob both
put coins into a two--
you know, into a
channel-like structure
where they both need
to sign, and then
they can say, OK, well, at the
end of the end of tomorrow,
whether it's sunny or rainy,
we distribute the coins.
The problem is, it gets
stuck if they disagree.
Right?
Also, rich players
are at an advantage.
They can say, well,
I think I'm right.
I'm fine not signing
to get these coins out.
It works great
with friends, sort
of gentlemen's agreement,
ladies' agreement, or shake
hands.
OK, yeah, you're right.
It was sunny.
But Bitcoin is the
currency of enemies,
so you want a third party to
decide in the case of conflict.
There's a lot of, actually,
interesting sort of game theory
things here where
people have tried--
I've seen reports--
like, I've been
to talks where people
are like, "Yeah, you
don't need an oracle.
You just agree on it without
any outside influence."
And there's some fun
things, some fun attacks,
where you can basically
say, OK, Alice,
it rains, you win, but I'm
not giving you the money.
And I can't get my
money back either,
but here's what I'll do.
I'll sign a bunch of
time locked transactions,
and if you want a little
bit of your money,
you can take it right now.
If you want more of
it, you just have
to wait weeks, months, years.
And then Bob can say,
OK, it's up to you.
Right?
Like, how much of your
money do you want back?
You can wait.
And so you're playing
off the time value
of money, kind of thing.
Anyway, so I have seen many
things where it's like,
you don't need an oracle.
Just have these
two parties agree.
And like game theory, hand wave.
But I have never been
convinced by them.
Like ultimately,
if we're in a bet
and we don't trust
each other, we
need some arbitrator to
decide the outcome of the bet.
OK, so you have a
third party, right.
You say, hey, we're going
to bet on this weather,
and if there's a dispute,
we nominate Jeff, over here,
and he's going to
be the one that
decides whether
it actually rained
or was sunny in order to
determine who gets the money.
OK, so you have
three keys, right?
You've got Alice and Bob who
are in the bet and you've got--
oh, well, that wasn't
how I thought--
Olivia, who is the oracle.
And if Alice and Bob are
chill, they both sign
and they don't even
contact Olivia.
Right, they're like,
yep, it was rainy.
OK, you get the coins.
Don't even involve Olivia.
She doesn't have to
deal with anything.
But if they fight and
they're saying, you know,
this is totally not raining.
This is like, right now,
this is not rain, right?
This doesn't count.
They're like, there's nothing.
It's basically sunny.
So if they fight about this,
they can ask Olivia to sign.
Either of them can
contact Olivia and say,
hey, my counterparty is either
unresponsive or uncooperative.
Can you sign?
And then sign off on the fact
that it is, in fact, raining.
I get the coins.
The problem is,
let's say it's sunny,
and then Alice tells
Olivia, hey, it's out.
Hey, it's Alice.
Say it's raining, and
I'll give you 0.8 points.
Right.
I'm not supposed to get
anything, but give me 0.2,
you get 0.8, win-win
for both of us.
So the oracle can be
influenced and bribed.
Right, so the problem here?
You've got interaction between
the oracle and the participants
in the bet.
Two of three multi sig oracles,
they see every contract.
Right?
The contract itself
is essentially
not a smart contract, really,
anymore because Olivia
has to know like the legal-ish
looking terms of the contract,
right?
Olivia, the oracle, has to
say, OK, in what case do I
side with Alice?
In what case do I side with Bob?
It could be programmatic,
but it could also just
be a sheet of paper with
a bunch of text on it,
and Olivia's an actual person
and determines based on that.
Right, so this is just sort
of a custodian arbitrator
kind of thing.
It's not that cool, like
high-tech cryptography
kind of thing, really.
Yeah, and they also
decide individually,
so they can equivocate.
So if everyone's
betting on the weather,
they don't have to sign
that it's sunny universally.
They can sign to sunny on this
side and rainy on that side.
There's nothing you
can do about that.
So I think what led me
to think about these,
it'd be better if the oracle
couldn't equivocate, right?
They can't deter--
you know, they
can't say two different things.
And it's even better if they
never see the contracts,
but how do we do that?
OK, so any questions about the
general setup of what we're
trying to accomplish here?
Bets?
And then you can have
multiple-- you know,
lots of different types of bets.
But anyway, this is
the essential problem.
How do we do this?
And like in Ethereum, most
of the time, everything's
on chain, right.
The data sources are published
on the Ethereum blockchain.
So you sort of have
similar problems.
There's ideas of, OK, let's
have a bunch of oracles,
and then you sort of take
the average of all oracles.
There's different
ways, but this thing
is, OK, make the oracles
never see the contracts.
But how?
OK, and then how is going
to be kind of complicated.
So remember these
from last time?
Right.
These sign with this key,
and you have to wait.
Sign with these two keys,
and you get it immediately.
This kind of same exact script
is like, so that will be used.
OK, and then a think I talked
about this on the third class
about signatures,
but we're going
to go more in-depth in
Schnorr signatures here.
OK, so in Bitcoin, we've got
this ECDSA elliptic curve.
In Bitcoin, you use ECDSA,
Elliptic Curve Digital
Signature Algorithm, which
is different than what
I'm going to explain.
But this aspect is
the same, right?
The public keys are private
keys times a generator point.
So we can do this without
actually using the Bitcoin
signature algorithm.
We can use our own external
signature algorithm,
and then use the keys generated
by that in Bitcoin itself.
OK, so a and b
lowercase, scalar.
Big A, big B, uppercase,
they're points on the curve.
So what operations can we do?
I think this is review, but
this was like months ago.
Regular numbers, you can
do whatever you want.
They're regular numbers.
It's easy.
Add, subtract,
multiply, divide, it's
literally in the software
just like BigInt.add,
and the BigInt addition and
mult-- you know, the BigInt
operations, if you actually
look underneath at the code,
they're real simple.
You're just adding numbers.
So you can do whatever
you want with these.
Points.
Points are a group.
They do not have two
operations defined.
They only have one
operation defined,
and we call that addition.
It's sort of-- like, you
could call it something else.
Sometimes, they use a
different symbol than plus,
but addition's sort
of what we call it.
And it works the way you'd think
addition would work, right?
You add these two things.
If you add A and B,
and then subtract B,
you get back to A,
things like that.
OK, so you can add and
subtract, but you can't multiply
or divide.
Right?
These are not defined.
OK, and you can
mix these things.
So you cannot add a
point and a scalar.
That's also undefined.
So if you have like a point
here, and you want to add 5,
it doesn't make sense.
However, you can multiply
a point by a scalar.
And you can divide a point--
yeah.
You can divide that.
And the way you do
that is you just,
in the actual elliptic curve,
you-- to double a point,
you take the tangent.
So instead of drawing a
line between two points,
you say, well, I'm drawing a
line between this single point,
which basically means the
tangent, as you sort of like--
things like limit as the
spacing between those two points
goes to zero.
And then if you can double a
point, if you can add A plus A,
then you can multiply by any
arbitrary number by saying,
OK, I'll take 2A
to be a tangent.
I'll take 4A to be
the tangent of that.
I'll take it A to A to
be the tangent of that.
And then you can add up,
like you can do binary
decomposition-- and computers
are real good at that--
and say, OK, I'm going to--
I need 5A, so I'm going
to take A plus 4A.
Right.
Now-- oop, yeah.
So you can divide--
divide's a little annoying,
but you can do that.
OK, so you've got all
these operations we can do.
You can do whatever you
want with the scalars.
You can add points, subtract
points, multiply these points
by scalars.
With this alone you can do--
and then, also, well, you
have to throw hash
functions in there
for the stuff we're
going to do, but you guys
know all about hash functions.
So with this and
hash functions, you
can do like ridiculous
amounts of stuff.
It's really kind of impressive.
Also, you can-- so yeah,
part of the signature system
is you pick some random point
G. Sometimes, in other systems,
you have G and H,
two other points.
But the idea is
everyone just agrees,
we've got some point G
and everyone agrees on it.
OK, a nice property.
You can add keys that
you can-- you know,
the addition sort of works--
addition in the scalar world
works in the point world
as well.
Right?
So if you have a times
G plus b times g,
and that's a point, that's
equal to a plus b times g,
also going to be a point.
So that is what
we're going to use.
And you can use
this to share keys.
Right, I think I
explained this last time.
If you know little a, but
you don't know little b
you can't sign.
But if you learn both, you
can sign for this, you know,
this summed pubkey.
So this is a way
to like share keys.
OK.
Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, like OK.
Well, that's sort
of out of order.
Anyway, Schnorr
signatures, which
are going to go into
Bitcoin probably
not even this year,
maybe next year,
and there's a lot of cool
things you can do with them.
I think I'm talking about
that next week in the term.
Like, that's aggregation, right?
But the basic idea of a
Schnorr signature, you've
got a public key that you've
already told everyone.
Right, so before
anything happens,
you pick a random private key
little a, multiply it by G,
and then compute big A and tell
that to the world either by
send-- having that as an output
address in your Bitcoin script
or publishing it on a website.
You know, somehow,
you propagate,
hey, this is my public key.
This is me.
OK, and then when
you sign, you come up
with another private
key, pretty much
the exact same as little a.
It's going to be
called little k.
And then you compute R, which
is k times the generator point.
So this R is pretty
much the same idea as--
it's another public key, but
this will only be used once.
And then to sign, you compute s,
which is k, that thing you just
made up, minus the hash
of the message the sign
concatenated with R
times your private key.
OK, and then the
signature is R and s.
And then for someone
to verify this,
they know m, right, the
message you're trying to sign.
They know your public
key, big A. They know R
and s, your signature.
And they try to--
what they do is they
just multiply both sides
of this equation by G. Right?
So you can you can do
that, same as regular math,
multiply both sides
by the same thing.
So they can't verify this
because they don't know
little a, they don't know k.
But if you multiply it by G,
well then you get s times G
equals k times G minus
this hash times a times
G. Well, that is just
your public key, right?
This is R. And
this, you also know
because they gave
you s, so you know
G. That is, you know s times
G. So that's how you verify.
And it's-- like, there's all
sorts of proofs about why you
can't forge these
and stuff like that,
but it sort of makes sense.
Right?
If you're trying to forge
a signature, and you say,
hey, I'm going to solve for s.
Right, well, I can't solve
for s directly because I don't
know little a, I don't know k.
The problem is, I want to--
OK, I want to solve for
one of these things.
I've basically got
an equation where
I've got R minus the hash of R,
and I can't tear those apart.
Right, like I need--
how do I-- OK, solve
for R, but there's
like the hash of R and R on
the same side of the equation.
I could try to
move this so that,
OK, R equals the hash of R?
Like wait, how am
I going to do that?
Right, so anytime
you try to solve,
you're going to have an R and a
hash of R in the same equation.
And, like, that seems
impossible, right?
OK, so this is
Schnorr signatures.
It works great.
It's got nice lots
of nice properties.
Actually, all of this
could work in ECDSA.
It's just that ECDSA is like
really ugly and complicated.
But anyway, so what
Discreet Log Contracts uses
is a fixed-R signature.
It's the exact same
equation, but you sort of
move where R is considered.
So before, you'd say,
the public key is A,
and now, my
signature is R and s.
Now, we're just going to
say, OK, make the public key
A and R, two points, and
make the signature just s.
So same equation,
everything's the same.
It's just that you generate
k at the same time you're
generating A, and publish both
A and R as your public key.
Right, no problem.
OK, the problem is you
can only sign once.
That's why you don't
usually do this.
There's no size difference.
Right, it's like, OK, well, your
public key gets twice as big
and your signature
gets half as big.
No net gain.
But you can only
sign once, and why?
OK, I'm actually-- it
looks kind of scary,
but it's actually not too bad.
So the idea is I sign.
I have an A and an R,
and those don't change.
Right, so I have a little a and
a k, and those don't change.
But I'm signing two
different messages.
So the idea is I have
signature 1, s1, which
is k minus the hash of
message 1 concatenated
to R times my private key.
Signature 2 is k minus
the hash of message 2
and R times my private key.
So I publish both
of these signatures.
And then someone says, oh, I'm
going to subtract these two
signatures from each other.
Right, so s1 minus
s2, well, that
would be this top thing
minus this thing, which
is k minus the hash
of message 1 times a,
minus k plus the hash
of message 2 times a.
The k's cancel out.
That's the important part here.
So k's are gone.
Cool, now I've got this s1
minus s2, which I can compute.
Right, s is just a
scalar, s1 minus s2
takes like a millionth of a
second on my computer to do.
Now, I've got this s--
you know, this thing
I know, s1 minus s2
equals the hash of message
2, R times little a, minus the
hash of message 1, R, little a.
I don't know a little a, right,
so I can't figure out this.
But I know what's on this
side of the equation.
Right?
I know this sort
of subtracted s.
What can I do here?
Well, I can factor out a,
right, because a is multiplied
on both sides of this.
So now I can factor-- you
know, put a little parentheses.
OK, this hash is message 2, R
minus the hash of message 1,
R times the private key here.
And now, I can divide.
And well, this is the
whole equation, right?
I divide out.
I divide by little a here.
The thing I know divided
by a thing I don't know
equals a thing I know.
Right, so I can move things
around and say, OK, well
then a is this thing I
know, right, the difference
between the two signatures,
divided by the difference
between these two hashes.
And those two
hashes, also, I know.
Right?
I know what the messages are.
I know what the R value is.
It works.
So the big thing here is
if you have the same k
value and the same a value,
you can find their private key.
So normally, this is OK
because k is different.
Right?
So you'd have k sub
1, k sub 2 here.
And then if you
build this equation,
you've got these k's
which do not cancel out
because you don't know what they
are and you don't get anywhere
with this.
OK, but so if you do
use the same k value,
you will lose your private key.
Fun fact, I first learned
about this in 2011
from the PlayStation
3 code-signing thing.
And yeah, that was when I--
I think, because I started
to get into Bitcoin
and, also, it was like, oh,
PlayStation 3 got hacked.
Cool.
So Sony had a k-- like,
they probably read up
on how to do this.
And they said, OK, k
needs to be random,
so they just made
a random number
and hardcoded it as
the k that they used.
I don't think they
realized that it has to be
random and different each time.
So it was just a
single random k.
Yeah, there's other cases
of this being a problem.
In bitcoin-blockchain.info, I
believe, a couple of years ago,
had something
where k was random,
but it was like only four bytes
of randomness or something,
and so you'd end up getting
some occasional k's that were
the same.
And then you could compute
people's private keys.
There's a couple other
things like that where if--
you know, so actually
in practice, now, you
don't make k randomly
in Bitcoin Core,
in most of the
Bitcoin libraries.
You make k basically the
hash of your private key
and the message so that it
changes for each message.
And it's also got like
secret information
so no one can figure it out.
That that's called RFC
6979, and it is safer
because you don't keep needing
new randomness each time.
Oh, yes?
AUDIENCE: Is this presented
for history's sake,
or are people still
making this mistake?
TADGE DRYJA: I
mean, will people?
Like, people have made it
in very recent history.
I wouldn't be
surprised if people
continue to make this mistake.
You know, a couple, two, three
years ago, Blockchain.info
had this where the
k's were the same.
It's not immediately--
you know, you
have to sort of look for it.
But yeah, people still make all
sorts of mistakes like this.
There's-- elliptic curves
are actually less, I think,
of a minefield then like RSA.
RSA has all sorts of
like, I had no idea
that would break the security
of the system, but it does.
Like, you know,
in an RSA, you've
got p and q, two big
prime numbers you
multiply to get your modulus n.
But if p minus 1 or
n minus 1 is smooth,
which means has
many small factors,
then you can break it and
find their private key.
Like, I didn't know that
until last year in a class.
I was like, really?
Oh, wow.
So there's all sorts of
bad things that can happen.
In elliptic curves,
it's kind of nice
in that your random numbers can
really just be random numbers.
So it's not too--
it's not as bad.
But you do have to watch out
for some of these things.
OK, so this new system, right,
if your pubkey is A and R
and a message m, right,
you cannot compute s.
So I know they're a public key.
Right, I know R. I know
they're probably-- like,
I know this whole thing.
I can't compute s,
right, because s
is in terms of k and little a.
I can compute s times G, though,
because s times G is in terms
of R and big A, which I know.
Right, so you can't
compute little s,
but you can compute
s times G. So
s times G is computable
for any given message.
So if someone publishes this
new type of pubkey, A and R
together, I can
say, OK, well, what
will it look like if you
sign the message, sunny?
Right, if you just take the
word sunny, stick it in here,
concatenate it with the R
value you already told me,
hash that, multiply
by your pubkey,
and then subtract that
from your R value,
I'll get a point on the
curve and I can compute that.
And I can compute
that for any m I care
to throw into this equation.
So this is kind of neat, right?
I can compute a point on
a curve for any message
that you have not yet signed.
And then the signature
itself would be s.
This sort of is looking
like a key pair, right?
So this is an unknown
scalar, right.
I don't know what
s is, but I can
compute s times G. This is a
public key, private key, right?
This is the exact same setup.
So now we can use this
for a third-party oracle
to sign messages.
And then when they
sign the message,
they're revealing a
private key to a public key
you've already computed.
So when I was making
this, I definitely
didn't start with Schnorr
signatures and do this.
I had my own crazy
scheme, which had
like all these different
equations and, like,
R was multiplied
by this other hash
and there was all these things.
And then I was talking to people
and eventually was like, wait,
you don't need all this.
This is just a Schnorr
signature where I already
know the R. So OK,
this is much nicer.
I don't have to write this
whole crazy proof and stuff.
OK, so we can use this.
And we can use
Olivia's signature, s,
as a private key in
our transactions.
And we use s times
G as a public key.
And then we can also
do the fun stuff
where we mix with Alice
and Bob's public keys.
Right?
So I can say that Alice's
pubkey plus s times G is
the public key
for this contract.
And Alice's private
key plus s is
going to be the private
key for this contract.
So I can say-- what we
can do is we can say,
OK, I'm going to
compute an address where
it's your pubkey
plus the signature
of this oracle signing
the word sunny times g,
and that's the pubkey
for Alice's sunny pubkey.
Right?
Alice can only spend this if
the oracle signs the word sunny
and she has her private key.
If the oracle signs
the word rainy,
Alice doesn't know
how to-- you know,
doesn't learn the private key.
Any questions about that part?
Make sense?
OK.
So this is kind of cool.
So what you can do, so
quick recap Lightning,
you'd use the mechanism where
you're adding these keys
to revoke old states, right.
You say, OK, if I
give you this key,
you can now spend
it immediately.
If I give you this key, you
can now spend it immediately.
So we enforce that with the
most recent one is the OK one
because if I broadcast
on these old ones,
you can immediately get it.
In Discreet Log, I
switch it around a bit.
I say, well, you know,
it looks like a channel.
We both put money into here.
And then we build three
different transactions
all at the same time,
before we even do anything.
Before we actually fund this,
we build these descendant
transactions.
And the idea is that the
public keys in here--
this is Bob's public
key, but it's also
got the sum, the sum
of Bob's public key
plus the oracle's signature
of the word sunny.
So if Bob broadcasts
it, and the only way
he can immediately
take his funds
is if the oracle
assigned the word sunny,
and he knows that s value.
If he broadcasts
it and then waits--
right, if he broadcasts it,
but it's not actually sunny,
then Alice can take the
money after a little while,
right, after a day.
You'd use the same
timeout procedure
where, OK if I broadcast
this and I know the key,
I immediately sweep it.
If I broadcast it and
I don't know the key,
my counterparty can take
everything after a day.
So yeah, all states are
created at the start.
The validity is determined
by the non-interactive oracle
signature.
So the oracle signs
cloudy, which is, yeah.
And now, either
party can broadcast
the cloudy transaction and then
take their money immediately.
If anyone tries to broadcast,
so if-- for example,
if Alice tries to broadcast
rainy at this point,
the oracle has signed
the word cloudy,
they're not going to
sign the word rainy.
If they do sign the word rainy,
they reveal their private key.
So if Alice broadcasts
this, her money's stuck.
She doesn't actually
have this key.
And then Bob just waits and
then takes all of Alice's money.
So you know, from the
network's perspective,
you can broadcast any
of these transactions,
but you don't want to.
Because you don't know the
key, it's not your funds.
OK, so yeah.
AUDIENCE: So the
wait piece, how does
that-- so if in the case
where it's cloudy, but Alice
signs the rainy key?
TADGE DRYJA: Alice broadcasts
the rainy transaction?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Alice broadcasts
[INAUDIBLE] transaction,
but doesn't have the proper
signature of the oracle.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah?
Do you just wait
because you know?
Then Bob just waits
because Alice's money--
yeah Alice, it's sending
to Alice's public key
plus the oracle's
signature publicly.
And Alice can't sign with that.
Right, she knows
her private key,
but she doesn't know the
oracle rainy private key.
So she can't sign with
this to take the money.
So the money's just
stuck here, but it's
got that timeout period, right?
It's--
AUDIENCE: OK, so before,
there's no timeout?
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, so the--
wait, did I have it here?
Yeah, it's the
same script, right.
In Lightning, it's PubR
or PubT and time, right?
There's a revocable
one and a timeout one.
Yeah, so in Lightning, it's
the opposite of Lightning.
Right, in Lightning, correct
is to use the timeout.
Right, so in Lightning-- whoa.
What just happened?
OK.
In Lightning, I broadcast this.
I have to wait, right?
It's Alice's key that then takes
a day, and then I can sweep it.
That's the correct
thing that happens.
If I broadcast this,
Bob can immediately
take it because I've already
given him the private key.
It's the opposite in
Discreet Log Contracts,
where if I broadcast the wrong
thing, it's just stuck forever.
I'm never going to
be able to get it,
and then my counterparty
can get it after a day.
If I broadcast the right
thing, my counterparty
can still get it after a day.
Right?
So if Alice
broadcasts this, Alice
has to immediately spend this
because, this Alice 5 Bitcoins
is also Bob's after a day.
So she needs to say, OK,
I'm going to broadcast this,
and then immediately
sweep the funds
to my own regular address.
So what's nice is that's
like a better timing model.
Anyway, so in cases of
fraud, the recoverable key
can be used, half
the key revealed.
So that's in Lightning,
right, and Lightning
broadcasts the most recent.
There is no PubR, right?
No one can sign this because
you haven't revealed it.
And then the timing
happens and sends.
So you broadcast your
most recent state.
You wait a little while, and you
don't actually have any rush.
You know you've never given PubR
away, so you can just leave it,
and then time elapses.
So maybe the timeout is one day.
You don't have to spend
it after that one day.
You can leave it for
a week or a month,
and then later spend
it because you're
really sure your
counterparty is never
going to get this private key.
So that's the way
Lightning works.
In Discreet Log Contracts,
however, the timeout one
is the incorrect one, when you
publish the wrong transaction.
Right, PubR is the
oracle's signature
plus your own private key.
And PubT is just the other
person gets it after a while.
So you should be
able-- you know,
if you publish the
right transaction,
you can immediately spend it.
If you publish the
wrong transaction,
you'll never be able to spend
it and your counterparty will,
tomorrow or next week.
So it's kind of a
nicer model, I think,
because, in Lightning, you have
to be watching your channels.
In Discreet Log
Contract, nothing bad
can happen if you go offline.
So that's really nice, right?
In Lightning, you have
to watch for fraud.
Old states could be broadcast
and you've got to grab it.
In DLC, sweep it as
soon as you want.
It's easier.
You have the software to
do both at the same time.
There's no surprises.
So for example,
in Lightning, this
is the current state, right?
Alice has nine coins.
Bob can, at any time,
broadcast this transaction,
and Alice must respond and
say, nope, that's wrong,
I'm taking all these nine coins.
And your software does that
automatically, sure, but you
have to be online and you have
to be watching the blockchain.
So surprises can happen.
And you know
there's software I'm
working on called Watchtowers
to anonymously outsource
watching this to other
people and things like that.
But it's a downside, right?
Fraud could occur
if you're offline.
In Discreet Log Contracts,
fraud cannot occur.
Eh, I don't want to say that.
There's all sorts of things
the oracle can do that's bad.
But the idea if I go offline--
right, I'm Alice, I enter into
this contract about the weather
next week, but then
I forget about it
and I just don't even sign
into my computer for a month,
there's no risk that the
wrong thing will happen,
you know, assuming the
oracle is signing correctly.
Bob can't do
anything bad, right?
If this is now
endorsed by the oracle
as being the
correct transaction,
if Bob broadcasts this or this,
he can never take those coins.
Right?
It's just indefinitely
stuck here.
Alice gets her coins
with no restrictions,
and Bob's coins are just
stuck there forever.
Right, he'll never learn this
the key to sign with this.
And so Alice can come back in
a week, come back in a month,
and say, oh, cool.
Bob broadcast the wrong thing,
and now I can take these coins
at my leisure.
If Bob broadcasts
the right thing
and then immediately
takes his coins,
Alice's coins are still there.
Everything's fine.
So this is, I think,
a nicer timing model
in that you don't have
to be online quickly.
Also, it's nicer in
that in Lightning,
if you're being honest
and you broadcast
the correct transaction,
you have to wait.
That's annoying, right?
The timeout could be a day
or a week or something.
And maybe your
counterparty-- you
know, if your counterparty's
online and co-operative,
you don't have to
use this transaction.
You can just say, hey
look, I want to close out.
I've got nine.
You've got one.
Let's just build a
transaction sending nine to me
and one to you, with no
weird scripts or anything.
And then Bob can say, OK,
sure, closing the channel.
Here we go.
And we just close it.
But if Bob's offline, which
happens, Alice says, shoot,
I have to close this channel.
I want my nine coins.
I broadcast this,
closing the channel,
and then I have to
wait a few days.
And that's annoying, right?
That's not great.
Whereas, in Discreet Log
Contracts, if you're doing
on it, let's say, I'm Alice.
Bob seems to be offline.
I can't contact him.
I'd say, OK, Bob,
you're not there.
Fine, well, it was cloudy.
I broadcast this.
I immediately take
my five coins.
I don't have to wait at
all, and the software
does both of those
at the same time.
So this is a nicer timing
model than Lighting.
Yeah, no surprises
and no waiting.
The only time you have to
wait is if the other party--
you know, Alice would have to
wait and if Bob broadcasts--
let's say, Bob broadcasts this.
Alice gets one coin
immediately and nine coins
after a few days.
So Alice is like, well,
I have to wait a little,
but, hey, I get all the
money, even though I was only
supposed to get half.
Great.
There are some attacks
where, for example,
let's say this was like
zero or like 0.001,
like basically nothing,
and the actual thing that
happened was it was raining.
And Bob's like,
shoot, I got nothing.
right?
Fine, I'm just
going to sign this.
You know-- sorry--
I'm just going to
broadcast this,
where I get all the money.
I don't actually get
all the money, right?
Alice is going to
take this after a day.
But basically, I lost
everything anyways, so fine.
Well, so that is an
attack where if there's
almost no money on one side,
Bob can be a jerk and say well
I'm going to broadcast the
invalid transaction just
to prevent my counterparty from
getting her money immediately.
She gets it all,
but maybe all is
pretty close to what she
would have gotten anyway,
so Bob has no real loss and
Alice has no real gain there.
And then Alice has to
waste some time waiting.
So that's an attack.
The easiest way to
sort of mitigate
that is to have this kind of
construction where it's like,
well, Bob still got one.
Even when Bob loses, he
still gets one coin back.
Right, there's extra
collateral in the contract.
And then he doesn't want to
broadcast the wrong thing
to be a jerk.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So if someone
broadcasts a wrong--
the wrong transaction,
the correct--
if he broadcasts the correct
transaction, it doesn't matter?
TADGE DRYJA: If-- well, from
the network's perspective,
right, so if I'm a miner
looking at the Bitcoin network,
I have no idea what
these things mean.
Right, it just says,
you know, key one coin.
Other key, nine coins.
You know, I just see two
different transactions
spending the same output.
So if you see Bob
broadcast this transaction,
you actually do not want to
broadcast this, probably,
because you'd rather have all
the money instead of half,
even if it takes you some time.
But if you have-- you're
saying, OK, I'm Alice.
I broadcast this, and then
Bob broadcasts this right
after, you're like, oh
shoot, that's a much
better transaction.
I would, you know,
but you don't know
which is going to get in because
the miners have no idea what's
going on.
AUDIENCE: It means
[INAUDIBLE] going
to be that you get your money?
TADGE DRYJA: What, sorry?
AUDIENCE: It would
be in the other case
where you used the
attack you just
talked about, where
people are broadcasting,
you get the money from it?
TADGE DRYJA: Oh, yeah.
Yeah, so if you see that Bob is
being-- the actual outcome was
it was rainy.
Bob sees this, and has
very little money at stake,
so Bob says, fine.
You know what?
Screw it.
I'm going to broadcast
this just so Alice
gets her 0.001 right
away, but has to wait
a long time for the 9.99.
Then Alice could say, uh uh uh.
I'm broadcasting this,
and then immediately
try to spend it with a high fee.
You could do that.
AUDIENCE: If I were--
TADGE DRYJA: Yes?
AUDIENCE: --to be
Alice, and it's cloudy,
then I would want to just wait,
in case Bob made a mistake?
TADGE DRYJA: You could.
Yeah, you could
hope that you're--
yeah.
So there's no rush, right?
The oracle signs it was cloudy.
You've both got
those private keys.
You can just wait.
You know, there's no need
to immediately broadcast it.
And once you
broadcast this, you do
need to immediately
spend the part that's
going to you because
that also has
the clause that it can go to the
other guy in a week, or a day.
So but, yeah, and you
can just leave it here.
You could just leave it.
Don't broadcast anything.
And you're like,
well, maybe he'll
screw up and broadcast
the wrong thing
and then I'll get all the money.
It's probably not
going to happen, but--
AUDIENCE: The oracle never--
so the oracle just goes quiet?
TADGE DRYJA: Ah, yeah.
So if the oracle--
there's all sorts of things
the oracle can do that's bad.
So if the oracle never
signs, none of these
will ever be valid, right?
So you should-- what the
contract should have is
a timeout where if--
you know, so if we're
betting on the price--
so we're betting on
the weather tomorrow,
we can say, OK, well,
by Monday, if the oracle
hasn't signed anything, we've
got a time-locked transaction
that just gives us
both back five coins.
Or, you know, it's a wash trade.
But, yeah, that can happen.
AUDIENCE: Set it to
destroy the oracle.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, so hopefully
the oracle doesn't do that.
OK.
But that's like, it's
not the end of the world.
It's like, OK, the
oracle's not there,
so we don't know how
to execute this trade--
you know, this bet, so we
just get our money back.
It didn't work,
and we wasted time.
Oh, OK, so some
scalability fun stuff.
You can do Discreet Log
Contracts within a channel.
So let's say you've got
a Lightning channel,
and if you want to cooperate--
if both parties cooperate,
no transactions get broadcast
to the blockchain at all.
This is kind of cool.
OK so you've got these
nested contracts.
So this is a Lightning
channel, right?
And it's Alice has 10
coins, Bob has 20 coins,
and they've been making lots
of different transactions.
This is, let's say, the 30th,
35th state of the transaction.
There's all sorts of
transactions before this.
but they've all been revoked
by sharing private keys.
And then you say, OK, well Alice
has 10 coins, Bob has 20 coins.
Let's build a contract.
So we both decrement
our balances by five,
and then we create
a third output.
So this is a--
it's sort of like having
an HTLC where you've got--
you know, as this-- sorry,
these arrows don't really
line up the right way.
But you've got one transaction
with three outputs.
Alice gets five coins.
Bob gets 15 coins.
And a new two of two
multisig gets 10 coins.
From that, you build
two different--
I should make
colors or something.
Yeah, these are two
different transactions.
This is all one
transaction, sorry.
So from there,
you say, OK, we're
going to build a Discreet
Log Contract that's
an output in the channel.
And we don't-- you know, if
we want to, we can broadcast
the whole thing.
Any of us at any
time can say, OK,
I'm broadcasting this current
state of the channel, which
is Alice five, Bob
15, Alice and Bob 10.
And then I have these
transactions as well,
and I can broadcast
either of those.
So if your counterparty
becomes unresponsive,
you close the channel
and close the contract.
But if the counterparty
is cooperative,
then the oracle signs,
OK, it was rainy.
This now becomes valid.
Both parties agree, yeah,
Alice won nine coins.
Bob can be a jerk and
just be unresponsive,
and then Alice is
like, all right, fine.
Close the channel.
Spend-- you know,
broadcast this transaction,
take the nine coins.
Alice has to do three
transactions in a row
to do that.
But if there's nine coins, you
know, that's totally doable,
right?
You know, this to close, this to
finalize the contract, and then
this the sweep the money
to herself before Bob
tries to get it.
But if Bob's
cooperative and says,
OK, yeah, you won
this bet and, also, we
keep doing these contracts, we
keep betting with each other,
this is the only valid one.
The other one I'm not
going to broadcast.
I'll never get the money.
And then we say,
well, Alice got nine.
Alice got plus nine.
Bob got plus one.
We just make a new
state of the channel.
Right, so this was the
old state, five, 15, 10.
We went up a level, and now
the new state is Alice gets 14,
Bob gets 16, and then
we revoke the old state.
So the contract was built. You
know, all the different terms
of the contract were
built. One of them
became known to
be valid, and then
they basically deleted
the whole thing
and they never touched
the blockchain.
Right, they saw this was
all descendent transactions
within a Lightning channel.
And now, we've got
our new balances.
So we can keep doing this.
We can have like five of
these at the same time
and then keep sequentially
making all these contracts.
What's nice about this is
no one ever sees anything.
Right, Alice and
Bob know that they
were betting on the weather.
Nobody else can
see that they were
making a bet at all, right?
There's no transaction that
goes onto the blockchain.
In the worst-case
scenario, a transaction
does go onto the blockchain.
And if you see
this get broadcast,
the thing is, it's still not
clear that it was a contract.
It could be a channel
within a channel,
and there's reasons to do that.
You could say, OK, this
is our cold channel
that we keep all
the keys offline
and this is our
hot channel that we
keep transacting very quickly.
And we can do some
things like that,
so there's reasons to do this.
But the scripts themselves, if
you broadcast the transaction,
look exactly the
same as Lightning.
It's just key A and time or
key B. So this is kind of cool,
I think.
OK, other-- oh yeah, I have
[INAUDIBLE] Other cool things
you can do, you can
split the R value
into an exponent and a mantissa.
So it's hard to explain.
OK, so let's say
I did the example
with like sunny and rainy,
right, but, in practice,
I think people are
going to use this
for futures contracts,
where there's
a bunch of different prices.
So you could say,
OK, the price we'll
put the price on this axis.
Price is $1, $2, $3,
$4, $5, for example.
And then Alice gets money here.
Bob gets money here.
And it can be like that,
or something where at $1
Alice gets all the money; at $2,
Alice gets most of it; at $3,
Bob gets most of it-- or half
and half, things like that.
What might happen
is that there's
like knock-in and knock-out,
where if the price is $6 or $7
or something really high, well,
all the money goes to Bob.
That's just how it is.
And like, you're not even
sure the order of magnitude,
so it might actually
go $1 and then $10.
Like, there might--
how do I do this?
There might be like
orders of magnitude
where, OK, the current price
of something we're betting on
is $20.
Right, so we actually
only care about the range
from $10 to $30.
We only care about-- and
then, like $20, it's Alice
and Bob get 50-50.
We might not care about
what happens if it's $0.01
or what happens if
it goes to $5,000.
We'll don't care.
Or we care, you know,
but the thing is
if it goes to $30 or $5,000,
the same outcome happens.
So what we can do
is we can say, OK,
instead of just using one R
value where the oracle signs
the price and we have to
compute messages for all
the different prices and
compute s times G for all
the different
prices, they can say,
OK, well, we've got R
exponent and R mantissa.
And mantissa is a weird
word for the thing that's
behind the decimal point.
So then I can-- so
exponent, you can
you say, OK, well, it's
either 10 to the one or 10
to the two or 10 to the
three or 10 to the four,
and I'm going to have
an R value for that,
and I'm going to produce
an s times G for that.
And then the mantissa could
be like one, two, three, four,
da da da to nine,
something simple like that.
So in some cases--
so, for example, in the
case of 10 to the two,
10 to the three,
10 to the four--
we don't care
about the mantissa.
Right?
If the exponent is 10 to
the two, three, or four,
then Bob gets all the
money, right away.
And if the exponent
is 10 to the zero,
then Alice gets all the money.
We don't have to involve
the mantissa at all.
But if the exponent is 10 to
the one, then we actually care,
and we can just add the point.
So we say, OK, sG equals R 10 to
the one minus the hash times A.
And then this is sG exponent.
And then, sG mantissa is
R3 minus the hash times A.
And then we can just
add these two points,
so we say sG exponent
plus sG mantissa
equals the contract sG
contract, and that's
what we put in our
contract for the keys.
That way, we need the oracle
to sign that the exponent is
10 to the one, and the number,
you know, the base is three.
OK, it was $30.
So that way, it's a little extra
data for the oracle to sign,
but pretty small, right,
an extra 32 bytes.
And then we can
potentially save on a lot
of these extra transactions out
in areas that all end up being
the same result to us.
Any questions about that?
Does that sort of makes sense?
It's an optimization.
Right?
You don't have to do it, but
it can lead to a lot less data.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So for the
mantissa, the 1, 2, 3, 4?
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Does that come from
a specific decimal place?
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
Well, it's-- the idea is the
actual number is going to be R
mantissa times Rx, you know,
or 10 to the Rx, right?
So the actual-- so
if the number was 20,
you say, OK, 10 to the one.
R exponent's 10 to the one.
R mantissa is two.
If the number was 5,000, you
say, OK, 10 to the three, five.
And then you just
release both of these.
And they're independent,
so that the two users
can use them independently.
And the most likely case is we
don't care about the mantissa,
we only care about the exponent.
So we're only-- some of our bets
only deal with the magnitude
of the price.
You could also do
bets where you're only
dealing with the mantissa,
but that seems kind of silly,
where it's like, I don't care
if it's $2 or $20 or $200.
But anyway, if the first digit
of the price starts with two,
you know, is two, I win.
You could do that, but
probably not as useful.
But yeah, and then
in the extreme case,
the extreme version
of this would
be to have bind--
you know, decompose
the number being
signed into binary,
and then find every bit.
And then there's
only two signatures
possible for every
bit, and then the users
can sort of combine these
things in any way they want.
More signature data,
but it gives the users
a lot of flexibility.
OK.
multi-oracle, another
thing you can do.
So the problem is,
how trustworthy
is this are these oracles?
The oracles can cheat, right.
They can just easily sign that
it's rainy when it's sunny.
That's publicly knowable, and
if they have a reputation,
that hopefully hurts them.
But you are trusting the
oracle to sign the right thing.
So maybe they want
to use two oracles.
So that's totally doable.
Right, you have the oracle,
the a oracle and the b oracle,
and you just add the two
points that you come up with.
And then when they both
release their s values,
you add those two s
points, and you'll
get the private
key, totally easy.
For n of m, there's
no size increase.
Right?
You just-- you can
pick 10 oracles,
add up all those things.
No one can tell.
And your transactions
are still really small.
For n of m, it--
or usually, it's
called m of n, huh?
Well, anyway, there's
a size blow up
because you're going to say,
OK, well, I want two of three,
and I have to make new
transactions for all
these different combinations.
And so you end up having
a lot of transactions.
For small things, like sunny
or rainy, it's totally doable.
For things like where
you're already hitting up
against limits
where, oh, we have
to sign thousands
of transactions
for all the possible
different prices,
then this can get very costly.
Another downside to this is if
they signed different things,
you get stuck.
Right?
So if we say, OK, we're going
to use Thomson Reuters oracle
and Bloomberg oracle
and we're going
to use their price of oil,
and then one of them signs,
oh, it's $50.03 and the
other signs that it's $50.
05, shoot.
We can't-- you know, we just
used the same value for all
these sG points to build
all the combined points.
Now, we don't have a match,
so we cannot build the point--
the private key that
we're looking for.
So this contract either reverts.
So that's another
reason why you might
want to decompose it this way.
You could have a
construction where you say,
OK, we're using Bloomberg
and Thomson Reuters,
but for Thomson Reuters
we're only using the exponent
and for Bloomberg
we're using both.
So the idea is if there's a
case where the exponent is
different between Bloomberg
and Thomson Reuters,
our contract fails.
But if the case is their
exponent is the same,
then we just go with the actual
precise price from Bloomberg.
So in case Thomson Reuters
gets hacked and they say,
oh, the price of oil
is $50 million a barrel
and that could cause
contracts to go the wrong way,
then that's sort of a
safety catch on there.
So there's all sorts of
things you can do like that.
I don't know how this
will actually work out.
Will there be lots
of different oracles?
My guess is no.
You kind of want
them to be reputable.
And you can't really
make money doing it.
And it's really scalable and
cheap to be an oracle because,
like, all you're doing
is signing things.
So it feels like
the kind of thing
that once you have a-- you know,
once you get some momentum,
you're just going
to be this monopoly
and everyone's going
to use the same oracle.
But who knows?
Yeah, oracle problems,
so yeah, oracles can lie.
They can also-- they
can they can equivocate.
Right, they can sign
two different things,
but then they reveal
their private key.
So you might want
them to post coins
on the blockchain with
their A, you know,
that's got their regular public
key A, so that if they ever
do sign two of the same message,
then they lose their money
and everyone can try to grab it.
Yeah, what are the other things?
Oh, I was going to
talk about novation.
We have time.
Yeah, so another
thing that people
like to do with these
types of contracts
is enter into contracts and
then sort of sell their position
in the contract.
So for example, if we were in
a contract about the weather,
and I look outside,
I'm like, oh, it's
definitely going to be
rainy, so the oracle
is going to sign about
the weather as of noon.
I'm like, it's 11 o'clock.
It's going to be rainy.
I want to sort of
lock in my profit.
And it's not exactly sure
yet, so there may still
be some value to
the sunny position,
but it's looking pretty
grim for the sunny position.
I might just contact
my counterparty
and say, hey, let's close early.
Right?
I don't need the entire
profit, but give me
90% of it because it's,
you know, pretty rainy.
And they might agree to do
that, but a better way to do it
would be to say,
I'm going to let
someone else take my position.
So for example, if you have--
so if you've got like Alice
and Bob are in a contract.
And then there's like Alice
gets nine, Bob gets one for sun.
And then Alice gets one,
Bob gets nine for rain.
And then they say, OK,
let's just do it early.
Bob might not be cooperative.
Alice wants to say, let's
just get out of it right now,
at some, at one of--
you know, a little
bit less than this.
Bob says, no, I want to
keep holding it through.
What Alice wants
to do is say, look,
I'm going to replace
myself with Carol.
Alice finds some other
person, Carol, to now
have a Carol-Bob
transaction where
it's the same exact contract.
So it'd be Carol nine,
Bob one and Carol one,
Bob nine for sun and rain.
So what's nice about this
is, from Bob's perspective,
nothing changes except the
counterparty's public key,
which Bob doesn't care about.
Right?
So Alice can say, hey, Bob
let's switch this transaction.
You have the same
exact payout based
on the same exact
signatures from the oracle,
so it's no change to you.
It's just that my
public key is going
to change because it's actually
going to be someone else.
And then Bob-- that
way, Bob's software
can automatically do it.
This is still interactive in
that Bob's keys have to sign.
Right, Bob needs to make a new
signature spending from here
to go into this new two of
two output, so that's new.
So their computer has to be
on and they have to sign,
but you can make the computer
software do it automatically
because there's no
user interaction needed
in that it's like, hey,
your position didn't change.
And then probably
put in something
where Alice pays Bob
a little extra, right.
Alice gives Bob a dollar or
two to incentivize him to leave
his computer on to collect fee.
You know, essentially,
it's like,
oh, if I leave my computer
on and my counterparty wants
to novate and switch
with someone else,
I might make a buck.
And my position doesn't
change, so cool.
So that is doable.
I do not look forward
to programming
that because that now has three
different computers talking
to each other and they
all have to do messages
in the right sequence and stuff,
and that's not the most fun
part of programming.
But yeah, so anyway, so
that's the idea of this.
What are some use cases?
I can think of some, but there's
all sorts of other ideas.
I think it can be pretty useful.
You could do currency futures.
So I think one of the biggest
would be dollar futures.
So right now, in CME,
I think, or CBOT or one
of those Chicago kind of
places, or both of them,
you can do Bitcoin
futures which are
dollar-settled Bitcoin futures.
Right, so you get
a bunch of dollars
based on the price of Bitcoin.
Yeah, so you can say,
I want 10 Bitcoins
for delivery on next week.
And then you don't
get the 10 Bitcoins,
but you get however
many dollars those 10
Bitcoins are worth based
on some exchange price
that they agree on.
You know, we're going
to use the average
of these different
exchanges and stuff.
With DLC, you could do sort
of the inverse of that, where
I have Bitcoins I
entered into a contract
where I have dollars
being delivered--
or, sorry, I have
Bitcoins, you know,
the dollar value
being delivered.
So the idea is I have $10,000
worth of Bitcoin being
delivered to me on Friday, so
if the price of Bitcoin goes up,
I get fewer of them.
If the price of Bitcoins
goes down I get more of them
such that the amount of
Bitcoin I receive on Friday
has a value of $10,000.
And that's a pretty
straightforward Discreet Log
Contract ability, right?
You just need to
know the price of a--
it actually ends up
being a lot easier
to think of Bitcoin
as the main currency
and then dollars as
the asset being traded.
So you sort of want to know the
price of a dollar in Bitcoins,
or how many Satoshi
is a dollar's worth,
and then you build your
contract from there.
And so if the price
of a dollar goes up,
you get more of these things.
So one side will say, OK, I've
got $10,000 worth of Bitcoin
coming on Friday.
The other side basically
says, I get whatever's
left in this contract.
And that other
side is essentially
like a more volatile Bitcoin.
So if the price of
bitcoin goes up, great.
Also, you get more of them.
And if the price of
Bitcoin goes down,
you're really screwed because
your Bitcoin's worth less
and you lose most of them.
But I feel like people
will want to do that.
Like there will
be people who are
like, cool,
double-volatile Bitcoin.
You know, where do I sign up?
And there's also
going to be people
who are like, I think
Bitcoin is cool,
but I want to anonymously
and trustless--
trustless, except
for the oracle--
you know, not so
trustfully short it.
Right, I want to
say, OK, I'm not--
I sort of don't have a
Bitcoin position anymore.
However, it's not the
same in that you don't
know who your counterparty is.
It's fully collateralized
at the outset,
so if the price of-- you know,
if both parties put in 10-- you
know, both parties
put in 10 coins,
20 Bitcoins is all that's ever
coming out of this contract.
Right?
You can't say, hey, I want
to do like a margin call.
You need to put like 40
more coins in this contract
because the price went down.
Your counterparty just
will say, no, I'm not.
So there's sort of
bounded loss and gain
for both parties at the outset.
Also, because you have no
idea who your counterparty is,
right, you can do this
totally anonymously.
It's-- I don't want
to say it's trustless,
because you are trusting the
oracle to report the correct
price, but your counterparty,
you don't trust at all.
Right?
You have no idea who they are.
You assume everything
they're telling you is a lie,
you know, like they're trying
to hack you, stuff like that.
So I think currency futures
would be a big one, where
people can then buy and sell.
Stocks might be a big one.
There's a lot of issues
there with insider trading
because if you can,
now, anonymously
trade stock futures,
I don't know,
that's probably
something people might
want to do who
shouldn't be doing it.
But it's hard to enforce
because these oracles have
no idea that anyone is
actually making contracts.
And if you look
on the blockchain,
you never see the contracts.
Or you might sort
of be like, well,
is this a Lightning Network
channel that closed or is this
a Discreet Log Contract
that just executed?
It just looks like keys.
You can't-- oh, that's
an important part.
Given, even if you're the oracle
and you know what you signed,
the fact that you're
adding these two points
means that unless you knew
the original Alice key,
you wouldn't be
able to tell, oh,
that's Alice's key plus my key.
Right, because you don't
know what Alice's key was.
It never existed independently.
Or, oh, Alice and Bob knew it,
but you didn't as the oracle.
And so no one will--
the oracles won't
know what contracts are being
executed, even after the fact.
You can, however,
prove that you used--
you know, if you want to.
If you're Alice, you can say,
hey, this was my contract.
I can show you all the terms.
And you can prove it by signing
a message with the Alice
private key and then also
showing that it's, you know,
this is my public key and I
added it to the oracle's thing.
Yeah commodities, sports,
there's all sorts of fun things
you can do with it.
It's pretty general,
conditional payments
based on any number or element
from a predetermined set.
Cool, so any
questions about this?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So, if the public
policymakers wanted to see
this, they absolutely couldn't?
It is [INAUDIBLE] encrypted?
TADGE DRYJA: You could
talk to the oracles
because they'll probably
be publicly-known entities.
And so you could say,
hey, oracles, don't sign--
don't sign messages.
I mean, yeah, but the actual
counterparties A and B,
if it's like OTC, if
it's just Alice and Bob
sort of talking to each other,
hey, let's build this contract.
We both trust Bloomberg.
Their prices are correct.
It's-- you can't see that
this happened at all.
AUDIENCE: Does Bloomberg have
to be complicit [INAUDIBLE]??
TADGE DRYJA: Bloomberg has to--
so some oracle,
someone, somewhere,
has to be saying, look, I'm
going to sign the price of oil.
That's it.
AUDIENCE: Even if they
disagree to, right?
TADGE DRYJA: Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
So well, so yeah, most of these
transactions never happen.
If Alice and Bob see
that the oracle signed,
they don't have to
actually broadcast it.
But they do need the
oracle's public key, first,
to build the contract.
So as you could try to
regulate public oracles,
but that seems like--
AUDIENCE: Assume Bloomberg's
bringing in, assume that--
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, yeah.
But, so the question is--
AUDIENCE: --they
have somebody sitting
in the Cayman Islands who's
got a software program that
grabs the Bloomberg fee?
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
The issue there
is the signatures
are sort of usable by anyone.
You could say, OK, well,
Bloomberg charges money
to provide these signatures
and these public keys.
But if those get out,
everyone knows, oh, these
are Bloomberg signatures.
You know, these are--
this is the Bloomberg data.
We can now execute
trades using this data.
And we do have--
so this eliminates
the trust between
counterparties,
but doesn't eliminate
the oracle trust.
But the thing is,
the oracle trust
is sort of the easy problem.
Right?
There's not too many cases of--
you know, if you have some
OTC contracts and you say,
oh, we're using the price
according to Bloomberg
or the price according to
the Wall Street Journal
or whatever,
generally that works.
So yeah, so what you can
do is, I think the place
that people will try to regulate
is the matchmaking area where,
if it's OTC, and
Alice just calls up
Bob and Alice is in
the Cayman Islands
and Bob is in British
Virgin Islands,
or whatever-- are
those the same thing?
I don't know.
They say, hey, I
want to short oil.
Oh, I want to go long oil.
OK, and we just build our
contract between our two
computers, and Bloomberg has
no idea we're doing this.
No one else in the world has
any idea we're doing this,
and we have this smart contract.
But in most cases,
people will not
know who they're wanting
to trade with, right?
They want some kind of exchange
where we can meet and say, hey,
I want to short Bitcoin.
You know, I want dollars.
And someone says, oh, cool I
want double-volatile Bitcoin.
Let's meet, and let's
make this a contract.
Those exchanges will probably
be more regulated, I guess.
You could sort of
say, hey, we need
you to KYC all your
exchange participants.
But even then,
like if you wanted,
so similar to Altcoin's
stuff now, you could say,
I'm operating an
exchange out of wherever.
And you can't operate an
oracle out of wherever, really,
because people won't trust it.
But you could say, I'm operating
an exchange out of Hong Kong.
We don't KYC anyone.
Maybe we'll get
shut down in a year.
But anyway, you can use
the Bloomberg data feed
and enter into these contracts.
So yeah, it makes
enforcement hard.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: It strikes
me that the hole
here, from the
public policy side,
is that even oracles
are semi-regulated,
and there's been tons
of fraud in oracles
for hundreds of years.
TADGE DRYJA: Really?
AUDIENCE: Oh, and massive.
TADGE DRYJA: But
they seem so useful.
AUDIENCE: You trust too much.
TADGE DRYJA: So people--
AUDIENCE: And you're a
Bitcoin Core developer.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah,
I just figured
that the financial
system figured that out,
so it's whatever.
No.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, sure.
Wicked loads of
fraud lots of years.
I used to run the Commodity
Futures Trading Commission,
so we did gold,
currency, interest rates.
TADGE DRYJA: So there, was
it that the spot market
itself was being manipulated?
Or the spot market says
the price price is $50,
the oracle says it's $80?
AUDIENCE: we would take
what the oracle was
publishing only because you're
long or short a position.
TADGE DRYJA: But then,
wouldn't you just sort
of sue people and say, hey,
look this oracle was wrong,
like obviously the
spot price was this?
It's not as--
AUDIENCE: We could [INAUDIBLE].
It's often hard to say
what is this spot price.
TADGE DRYJA: Right.
AUDIENCE: And sometimes, you
come in at different places.
Besides, it seems
like the holes,
the holes here, is not so much
around the oracles, which there
could be big holes like,
somebody could just
become an aggregator
of the oracles
because the CMA
takes four prices,
but somebody sitting
in the Cayman Islands
could say we're going to just
take the same four prices right
[INAUDIBLE].
And being crypto, settle.
If it's fiat, settle.
Just travel more ways to get
into the on-ramps and off-ramps
to the banking system.
But and that's why you're
seeing a lot of exchanges having
a hard time getting, basically,
deposit accounts in banks
because the banking
regulators around the globe
are trying to regulate
on-ramps and off-ramps,
but it's harder for crypto
and crypto exchange.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, crypto
crypto, start a computer.
Yeah, you've got it.
You don't have to ask.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And you could
have it, and you know,
so over-the-counter Cayman
Islands aggregator oracles,
and somebody could do
single-stock futures that are
banned in this country, so--
TADGE DRYJA: Really?
AUDIENCE: Single-stock futures.
TADGE DRYJA: Well,
options aren't, right?
AUDIENCE: Options aren't.
TADGE DRYJA: So,
oh, I didn't say,
you want to make options
contracts with this,
you just don't give
the data to one side.
It's basically the same
construction, but like, now,
Alice has the option to
broadcast the transaction
and Bob doesn't.
But so you can make
options with this--
or futures, I mean.
AUDIENCE: But you're not trying
to subvert public policy norms.
This could be a gray
technology, or do you
think that is useful for
subverting public policy norms?
[LAUGHTER]
TADGE DRYJA: I think
it has both use cases.
One of the big ones will be sort
of similar to Bitcoin, where
it's like, hey, I can do these
things that maybe I'm not--
you know, people
don't want me to do.
And in some cases,
the don't want
me to do is just like
scale in terms of like,
OK, I'm some guy in Thailand,
and I want to go long Apple.
And probably, you
can legally do that.
But if you've got like
a couple hundred bucks
and you're in some
random country
and you want to go
long, some US equity,
that's not really feasible.
Right?
Maybe you can open accounts.
Maybe you can try to
open a foreign account.
Like it's-- there's
a lot of friction.
And so with this
kind of thing, it's
like, hey, we've got a Bitcoin.
I trust this price oracle.
OK, I'll do it with
like a couple hundred
bucks worth of bitcoin.
That said, there's also
cases where it's like, OK,
I work at Foxconn
in Shenzhen and I
think the Apple
iPhone 11 is not going
be any good, so I'm
going to short Apple
using this kind of technology.
So there will be
good and bad things.
You could also-- it could also
be useful in cases between
actual regular legal
Wall-Streety kind of people,
maybe not-- where--
then again, it's
good where you've
got like not a lot of trust
between your counterparties,
but you do trust some
kind of oracle feed.
And the other thing
is-- like, I have talked
to this sort of
Wall-Streety people,
and they don't really like it
because they're like, wait,
there's no leverage.
Right?
You have to put all
the money you're going
to get in at the beginning.
And they always want to have
it like super-leveraged.
You can crank up the slope.
So you can say, OK, we
both put 10 Bitcoins in,
but a small difference
in price, right,
so like a 5% movement
in a price will
like make all the money go
to one side or the other,
so we hit the knock-in
and knock-out really soon.
So you can do that, which
is kind of like leverage.
But fundamentally, it's
only the Bitcoins that
go into the contract come out.
So yeah, I don't know how
this will be regulated.
I'm working-- there's a
company in Japan who's
interested in building
this technology.
There's like-- it's a brokerage
that's making this stuff.
I'm working on it with
some other people.
We'll see.
I don't know how it will be.
Maybe people won't like it.
It's-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: I mean, it
seems to me like that's
one of the big things
that Bitcoin's missing.
So if the financial
system is for distributing
risk and [INAUDIBLE]
the risk, right now,
I don't really do
that with Bitcoin.
It's kind of just a
transactions channel.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So this--
TADGE DRYJA: I
think it'll be cool.
AUDIENCE: --be logically,
kind of the next step.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, oh I
think this'll be cool.
I think people would use it.
I just, you know, it's
a lot of work to program
and I don't, yeah,
have enough time.
But there's other
people starting to get--
I don't know, it's weird.
It's sort of like Lightning
was like three years ago,
and some people
were like, oh, cool.
And then eventually,
people were like,
oh, this is a really big deal,
and let's all work on it.
And it might be
the same with this,
where like no one really cares
and then, eventually, people
will be like, oh, hey we should
build this and use it and start
companies and things like that.
So hopefully, people
will get into it.
I think it's a pretty
nice construction
for these kinds of things.
It competes-- there's things
like Augur, which is--
I don't think is the best idea.
It, like the Augur, the idea is
the oracle is sort of everyone,
and like everyone votes
on what these outcomes
for different things were.
But yeah, I don't know.
I don't know how far along they
are in terms of their software.
But that was also like
two or three years ago.
And this could be
applied more broadly,
like where anytime you have
Ethereum-type smart contracts
or something where you want
some external oracle who
then can sign things.
And then you can use it in a
way where the oracle's signature
doesn't show up after the fact.
So anyway, any questions?
Sounds good?